now why did you decide to come as the
Joker and Batgirl today Batgirl well
she's like completely obsessed with
Batman and we would thought well might
as well going to main characters and the
villain as the Joker your great villain
aren't you now why do you like him so
much he's very he's got a soft side to
him you just need to look for it he's
right he's a sensitive man you just need
to look deep in there he's a wonderful
person
deep Italy yeah you do feel it's been
the best person who's betrayed him in
the movies for you well in the movies
I'd say Heath Ledger obviously but my
favorite Joker is Mark Hamill the boy
said the Joker in the video games how
excited are you to see the Dark Knight
Rises
really excited spoke close it's been
waiting so long what are you looking
forward to just Batman like the whole
the whole storyline is going it's just
amazing now we know you're not the
villain in this one are you be still
looking forward to it I'm really looking
forward to it I'm insanely excited yeah
obviously I'm a bit jealous of Bane but
you know ultimately I am the better
villain do you think so why are you
better than vain yeah I'm smarter I'm
sleeker I'm just sexy a person really
talking about being sleek I'm loving
your outfit how did you put it together
I had the suit made because I need a
suit for sixth form so I thought why not
go through your draco suit and my dad
made the bowtie I know the green dye
going on in your hair there die
so natural green color that you saw that
you are blessed with yeah I'm blessed
with mental green and ginger hair I like
the makeup as well that's take long to
do well we did it about six o'clock in
the morning and we did try and aim for a
neat look so you can sort tell that
didn't quite work out she bought the
whole outfit because I was going to make
it but then I didn't really have a lot
of time because I was deciding between
Batman and Batgirl and I was like
there'll be more Batman here
now there's been a quiet Batman haven't
there is there been one that you thought
now he's the really that he's the really
good run yeah yeah I describe him but
there's so many but as he's got his suit
he said it was made out for Kevlar I
thought it was amazing it looks really
good
you